من عالم التقنيه العالم الذي نعيش فيه
ويمتلك كل ما نملك ان صحه تعبير بكل بساطه
اذا كنت تستخدم هاتفك في تصفح مواقع
التواصل او في تعاملات شرائيه وبنكيه
فانت بذلك فتحت باب تسريب بياناتك الشخصيه
بناءا على التحولات التي حصلت خلال العام
الجاري في عالم الانترنت يتوقع خبراء
التقنيه ان يشهد عام 20 23 تغيرات في مجال
الشراء الالكتروني او حتى الخصوصيه لهذا
حذرت مؤسسات حكوميه وخاصه من اتساع عمليات
الاحتلال وقدمت عده نصائح لتجنبها ابرز ان
نصائح تتمحور حول التحذير من زياده
الرسائل البنكيه المزيفه التي تصل لك عبر
الهاتف المحمول وتحمل اغراءات بالكسب
السريع شركه كسبريس كي المتخصصه في الامن
السيبراني وضع تصورا لعالم الرقمنا من
ابرز ملامحه لان الهواتف الذكيه سيكون لها
مكان اكبر في تعاملاتنا وسيصبح نموذج جزء
من الواقع المزيد عن هذه التصورات معك على
كميه البيانات التي نصدرها عن طريق اجراء
المدفوعات الرقميه اضافه للبيوت الذكيه
والسيارات المجهزه بالكاميرات قد تجعل
الخصوصيه شيئا من الماضي ومع تتبع سلوكيات
المستخدمين وضعت شركه كاسبر سكي تصورا
يحمل مزيدا من الرقمنه في عام 2023 ونصائح
للحفاظ على الخصوصيه الخبراء توقعوا مزيدا
من الاعلانات الموجهه لنا المبنيه على
سلوكياتنا خاصه من شركات مواقع التواصل
والتسوق مثل متى وامازون وجوجل لكن هذه
الشركات تظل امنه على الخصوصيه بالنسبه
للمواقع الاصغر كما ان الهواتف الذكيه
ستحل بشكل اكبر بدل المستندات الورقيه بل
وستكون بديلا ايضا للبطاقات المصرفيه
البلاستيكيه في بعض البلدان كذلك ظهور
المزيد من المخاوف حول خصوصيه علم المترس
الذي لبعض بانها قائمه اصلا بوجود الهواتف
الذكيه وانترنت الاشياء
[موسيقى]
دكتور امين حاسبيني مدير فريق البحث
وتحليل العالمي في كاسبر سكي اهلا بكم
دكتور معانا في صباح العربيه هناك توقعات
وتصورات لعام الانترنت خلال العام المقبل
2023 هناك مزيد من الرقم انا والكثير من
اختراق الخصوصيه على الانترنت ما هي
التوقعات كاسبر سكي بدقه
صباح الخير طبعا
لما نتحدث نحنا عن التوقعات طبعا اللي
احنا بنشوف انه يتم يعني
للجميع ان كان المؤسسات او افراد ان احنا
نتبنى التكنولوجيا بشكل مطلق في حياتنا
اليوميه بشكل متزايد
وطبعا هذا هذا يعني ياتي بحسنات وياتي بس
سيئات ايضا ااه لدينا مخاوف طبعا من
التحديات
التي يواجهها العالم منها التحديات الجيو
السياسيه اللي هي تسبب في ازدياد الهجمات
وطبعا هنالك همم مخاوف من ازديادها بشكل
متطرد ان كان من الجهه الاجراميه او من
الجهه المستهدفه في السنه همم
ايضا من موضوع العالم الافتراضي اللي همم
يدخل همم الى منازلنا الى اماكن عملنا
بشكل متسارع ايضا همم احنا نرى يعني انه
طب هنالك احتمالات لكي يعني يستبدل
التابلت عند اطفالنا في شكل قريب جدا ايضا
سنه نسمع عن مصطلح الحرب العالميه الرقميه
الاولى يعني هناك تخوفات من هجمات
الكترونيه هجمات سبرانيه قادمه هل هذا
كلام مبالغ فيه
يعني هذا ليس ليس همم ليس مبالغ فيه نحن
نرى مؤشرات لهذه الهجمات يعني احنا
المخاوف الاساسيه هي ترتبط خاصه بالهجمات
على البنيه التحتيه الحيويه الطاقه المياه
همم التصريف
والشبكات الانترنت والبنوك
فهذا كله طبعا همم يعني يدخل ضمن همم
استراتيجيات الامن الرقميه همم عدد كبير
من الدول لكن هنالك امثله حقيقيه لهذه
الهجمات شفنا اطفاء عدد من المدن همم يعني
وابعادها عن الكهرباء في السنوات الماضيه
شفناها هجمات على محطات تكرير النفط او
تكرير مياه همم هذا كله يعني
نعمل ان لا يتوسع بشكل مكثف خاصه
انه نحن نعتمد بشكل مطلق ااا بازدياد على
على التكنولوجيا
دكتور يعني كخبير في الامن السيبراني انا
كفرض من المجتمع يستخدم كثيرا من زمان
يستخدم العمق العملات الماليه عبر
الانترنت هل من حلول امنيه لتجنب الهكرز
او الاختراقات والقرصنه عبر الفضاء
الالكتروني
طبعا هنالك عدد كبير من الحلول
للجهات الامنيه والجهات الحكوميه لجهات
البنيه التحتيه للبنوك والافراد ايضا
وتبدا هذه الحلول همم
الوعي الالكتروني الوعي على مخاطر امن
المعلومات الوعي للمشاكل اللي ممكن ان
تواجهنا نحن واا هذا يسعدنا ايضا على
التاقلم على مثل همم مثل التعلم قياده
السياره همم طبعا هذا هذا يعطينا المجال
لان نكون همم اشخاص مسؤولين عند استخدامنا
للتكنولوجيا
بشكل همم
من الدوله
مثلا هي اكثر دوله محصنه الكترونيه يعني
لديها جدار ناري عظيم كما يسمونه كيف يجب
ان تبدا الحكومات والدول بوضع حد للهجمات
الالكترونيه ربما توظيف جيش الكتروني مثلا
جميل يعني جميع الدول وجميع الافراد لديهم
مسؤوليات وجميع المؤسسات الكل لديه
مسؤوليه من نوع معين الحكومات تقوم
بالامكانيات التي لديها المؤسسات يجب ان
تقوم بالامكانيات التي مطلوبه منها
والافراد ايضا الوعي
والتبني التكنولوجيا يجب ان يحصل على جميع
المستويات
وهذا هذا الحل الوحيد يعني طبعا الدول
لديها امكانيات اكبر لديها امكانيات اوسع
طبعا همم لكن همم ايضا للمؤسسات والافراد
شكرا جزيلا دكتور امين المدير